Kim Kardashian embrace her silence on  the Paris robbery and Kanye West's  hospitalization dipper - Ian robbed at  gunpoint they're gonna shoot me in the  back there's no way out every story  you've heard is bigger than you know  we're so close we feel each other's pain  I quit - me so upset the thing about it  we love spending time with one another  every lie every laugh is louder every  shop has inductance don't scare me  please what's going on I think he really  needs me and I have to get that's the  new promo for Keeping Up with the  Kardashians a new season a source  previously told DT Kim isn't ready to  address the robbery in an interview yet  but she obviously talks about it on the  reality show the series returns in March  how do you agree so stand dry would be  normal yeah let's say you look that  promo comes just days after Kim returned  to social media following a three-month  break  you